hello
welcome to the active inference lab this
is math stream
1.1 our first math stream
and we're really lucky today to be able
to have some time with
shanna dobson and we're going to be
talking about emergent time and
chromatic types
and hear a lot more on this topic and
also check in with everyone's questions
that are in the live chat or in the
comments later
but first we'll just quickly introduce
ourselves and then hear a presentation
and then have a discussion
so again i'm daniel and i'm here with my
co-organizer sarah so maybe sarah say hi
and then pass it off
uh hey um sarah calling in from walk
down forever berlin germany
and um i'm looking forward to
talking to shayna dobson
hey sarah thank you thank you for a nice
intro hello everyone my name is shanna
and uh i am uh i'll be a graduate
student in the fall but i've studied a
whole bunch of stuff
in the middle um i'm kind of a i guess a
polymath that
got a bunch of degrees at once and um
did a masters and i'm a i was hired
right away as a full-time lecturer kind
of everywhere
and um found a couple topics that i'm
pretty interested in
so let's see if uh if this can be
exciting for someone
shayna dobson sorry
okay daniel can you see this okay yep
all right am i ready to go okay good
um great all right so i want to talk
about
um emergent time and chromatic types and
you know maybe um i mean it's up to
y'all if you want to ask me questions as
i go or maybe hold them because i'm
trying to
constellate uh what's going on here
you're gonna see there's some heavy
topics involved
but i try to make them um as beautiful
and palatable as i can
so uh let's just get right to it what
are these and what am i talking about
so i have a few questions um kind of
driving this independent of the
mathematics i'm trying to make this not
super math focused i was trying to make
this kind of
more applicable to everyone because the
math that i do is super niche
and i was trying to not do that and be
like a non-inclusive
so the big questions the philosophy
questions that are driving me is what
is time um is there anything that isn't
time
time is always modeled as either just
like a geiger counter or it's
this sort of accepted background
phenomena and i don't really agree with
that i feel like we haven't
focused too much on it people think like
where is it
you know i ask like uh sometimes i give
talks and my uh my first uh question is
like where is yesterday and of course
people like what you know you could zoom
out and look at like the light you know
the light cone data and things like that
but it's like phenomenologically really
interesting where is it
and you know uh will it always be here
and i remember i was talking to rafael
bouzou and
he's got this great paper about like you
know i mean is it will it always be here
and
maybe it's not um maybe it it sort of
just maybe
you know it came at some point as well
hence i think it's sort of
emergent so and i like wasn't always
here and
here's probably not the appropriate word
you're going to see that i love language
so again i'm super poly math and i
a lot of my math papers are super math
philosophy
and so i think there's a lot of
problematic terms
that we need to actually go into and so
i actually say where's non-archimedean
time
you know so um not an archimedean the
you know the
uh to be archimedean is to believe in
infinite decimals that you can always
have a number bigger or lower and
in quantum mechanics you really have a
cut off right so if quantum mechanics is
modeling
you know cut-offs as um you know spatial
cut-outs as
non-archimedean why is time not also
non-archimedean so i'm very interested
in that
what would that actually look like let
me go heavy into that so
um you know sarah i had the iliyah
that's derrida
in the french continental philosophy
saying that there's always a there is
in mathematics we always go there exists
you know there exists an
x such that whatever and so that's very
powerful the existential quantifier
right
but and qualifier but i'm you know what
are the conditions for existence
this is something chris fields and i are
working on like you what are those
not just like metabolic conditions i
mean all of this
you know so i think the big bang is a
real problem
and uh like going into that of course
you have all these wild theories about
you know well you know it's like a a
white you know like a white hole that
passed through something else and all
this kind of stuff
but i'm really interested in like what
are the conditions to even have
existence
right so uh what what would the
conditions be to have a discretization
of time
what does that even mean so what is
entropy and a temporal discretization so
we have this like very vague notion of
entropy and i agree with uh like max
tegmark that there is no objective
notion of entropy you're like oh
well there's a local you know influx of
energy here but
you know uh the environment surrounding
it lost energy so there seems to be a
calibration there you know
so my whole point is to uh categorify
the stop mechanism just like chris
talked about in his last talk
um you know biologically speaking like
when to stop
uh like you know cellularly dividing the
the stop mechanism
on the bio level is very very very
intricate in my opinion
and so i'm wondering like how would you
categorify that i mean like using
category theory
uh so i'm my whole vibe here is to try
to actually upgrade the mathematics
that's used
in modeling some of these things again
my head is pretty abstract
so i see things abstractly but i think
it's a gift because it's allowing me to
see connections
in a non-linear way so my brain is
definitely non-linear and i try to use
that in linear
phenomena so i say you know how can we
say you know there exists a time
asymmetry but it uses this
like phrase well when there is no
objective notion of entropy
i think it's really really tricky
there's also no proven structural
causality
all right and sarah you had this you
know the light cone it's a little vague
right there's some problems uh with gr
there's some problems with the
formulation of light cone and things
like that
um light cones wouldn't withstand
quantum mechanics and stuff like this so
um i
firmly believe you know just like
bertrand russell that there is no
structural causality and it leads you
into these great things like
last thursday-ism and you know the world
was made five minutes ago
and there's really no logical
impossibility in saying that
so i have not seen a structural
causality
and so again chris fields and i agree
with this and that's why we're writing
this cool stuff
number eight why do we actually
experience memories this is actually um
like why a lot of this is very um
again taken for granted and so i'm
really interested in
like why that is of course people say
you have memories to prevent you from
you know falling off a cliff again
like association and base pavlovian
uh you know survival and that's not what
i'm talking about right
i'm actually talking about re like how
why do you experience
them somebody like me like a total
precog like i remember everything
and sometimes i can get you know haunted
by thoughts like memories that just come
come in and i um i know there's a lot of
people like that maybe you're just
taking a test
and these horrible memories just fly in
your head or maybe they're really good
memories right
but the experience of that is very
strange nobody knows what a thought is
right i remember sarah i think you asked
in ser and chris's talk
you know what what is a thought and i've
i haven't heard anything about what
those are people oh quantum fluctuations
and things like this yeah but
there's something else going on because
you know for instance like
the speech that i just said i read
number eight
like two minutes ago and uh so the
speech is gone right it dies but
something remains
and so uh what is that it seems like
there's a hologram
copy of everything that you say that's
actually stored in the brain
and you're doing some kind of recall
with that but i don't understand storage
if everything is discrete
and so that's why this is very complex
and very beautiful so i say what
what are they like what is the
fundamental unit of thought you know
alan watts is going to say so oh it's
like existence and i'm not really sure
what the bio people are going to say
what is it you know um what is not a
thought
you know so for me you're going to see
that i'm going to invoke this pro finite
condition a pro finite set
is a um a compact totally disconnected
space it's so it's
it's like a canter set so i think that
what's happening is time is like a
canter set
and somehow you are recalling over a
cantor set
what is a thought that no idea right um
no idea how we're even speaking to each
other so i think we actually need to go
over what that is these are just the
questions having begun the talk right
so questions two right what is causality
like what is it again if i don't believe
in structure you know oh a came before
b that's very reference frame dependent
and reference frames
are flimsy right and so i say well
causality for him
and then i say well what is a
measurement that's very tricky right of
course the quantum problem
and um just measurement in general yeah
and i say well what is a reference frame
that's even worse
um you know according to me my world
according to me
and like who is me and so that's going
to be tricky
so chris and i you know both agree like
what is this personal identity
over time and you've got big branches of
philosophy like pedurantism and
endurances i'm trying to just
trying to figure out what that is right
uh
who is this right uh is
is me today the same as me yesterday
well clearly not
because the cells are doing a whole
bunch of things right we don't have any
of the same cells that we used to have i
mean maybe some neuronal things
but um you know you have a boundary and
so what's happened so i you know i don't
understand what over time means i don't
know how anyone can be over anything
so then you know um sarah i said well
isn't you know uh shouldn't you talk
about space time and i'm like that's
just a manifold it's like one of the
most basic structures in mathematics and
we have more sophisticated mathematics
so i don't really vibe with uh
the manifold thought i think you can
really
really sparkle and dazzle that up to see
what's actually happening
i don't know if you actually have to
unify them like that you know um
you could just be spatializing time
instead of leaving time as it is
so then i'm like okay if you want to
just use like uh manifold and
differential geometry you could also go
number theory
so like what would a number theoretic
time look like and what would like a
number theoretic space look like
so you don't have to just like my whole
point is that
physics like the the framing of physics
is based on the mathematics at the
current time
so a lot of quantum mechanics is like
linear algebra and operator theory but
you could also
up that and make it like algebraic
number theory and then you'd get new
physics so with me
if you give new math you get new physics
so upgrade the maths
you know so like what is a number
theoretic black hole that sounds a lot
cooler to me than
the you know the the framing of the
black hole the old model has a lot of
problems
can you also like see me okay yep okay
cool
all right so let's go through this
outline and again i'll just keep the
talk
um at like an hour and then um
all right so here we go so those are my
like big questions kind of funneling
everything
um so i'll talk about discrete time i'm
going to really firmly say that there is
no synchronous reference that everything
that's happening now already happened
you do have like a lot of time in the
brain
to process so there is nobody's
experiencing anything as it is
and things like that i'm also going to
say that there really is no self
reflexivity because i
i don't know if that there's a self and
so
chris and i are trying to actually
formulate all this together right so i
really don't think there is a productism
or an endurantism with those two
philosophies that are trying to say
you know that you exist as a
four-dimensional being and you kind of
exist
through time and i think there's some
problems with that
so problems within produrantism or
endurance is like oh i get cut and i
have a reaction later
those those pieces of you were supposed
to be independent but they're not
we're in touch with our pain but they
would say that it's like not
so it's it's a little tricky um i think
there is no personal identity over time
i have no idea how this is happening
there's like a reset happening
every every um every whatever you
may not want to say plank time but if
there's not personal identity over time
there's definitely you know so i think
uh the memory whatever it is has a
singular support
the support is the um the um
the the you know places where a function
is
not zero so if you only have singular
support then that means you're not zero
on a singular set
so it's actually uh again i'm i'm trying
to upgrade the mathematics used in all
of this to
fractals and cantor sets things like
that i'll introduce chromatic types and
chromatic types is going to be this new
spin that i'm working on um
that's sort of paralleling what's called
a homotopy type
a new holographic principle based on
these diamonds uh that i really like
and emergent time okay so for the why
how and to what extent that i was asked
to kind of fill out i said why because
this day there does not exist a coherent
formalism of emergent time nor
discretization of time
imagine there is no continuum right
that's a huge uh it's a huge statement
what exists actually between the
discretization what is emergence
how can we again our complexity class
complexity class in the sense of turing
degrees that's what i'm referring to
so not equivalence classes sarah but
like the turing degree equivalent
that you still have this like there is
and that's the
physics of time equivalent of a
meaningful president but it's absent of
all kazoo stream because industry is
like a softest tree we have a
we have lots of physics sophistry and
mathematical sophistry and i'm like can
we actually
try to figure out how we can actually uh
have
existence with this uh discretization of
time
independent of any kind of conniving you
know so how well we're gonna you know
hopefully have a wondrous introduction
discretization mathematically all that
is uh commissioner with it okay
so um i'm into a lot of uh
mathematics um where you can construct
spaces
based on algebraic spaces so
i'm going to try to go really lightly
through this because this is pretty
heavy
but um so you can quotient out a scheme
which is like a higher dimensional
notion of an algebraic variety
by a pro-ital equivalence relation pro
tells us
a certain topology an equivalence
relation is going to be a gluing
so you get this diamond which is a sheaf
on a category
in a category called perfectoid spaces
so this diamond has these quote
impurities which are these geometric
points i refer to
so this is a notion from peter schulza
and i
really like the the diamond idea and um
so what happens that you have this uh
this geometric point which is a morphism
of schemes
and it's almost like um so it's it's
sort of like this that there are
mathematical impurities in this object
and so
when you have a normal diamond uh you
have you know different colors on it
that are reflections of the impurities
but you don't ever actually see the
impurity itself
you just see the reflections of the
impurities and so you're never
actually getting the thing you're
actually only getting shifted
versions of a reflection that's what i
think is going on here
right so you have your uh you know your
interface
and no one's ever actually experiencing
the thing just a profiling many copies
so
you could you can pull this morphism of
a scheme back which is a topological
move
and you can get this what's called a
profanity many copies of spa
see this is the attic spectrum of an
algebraically closed
curve so you can make these products spa
c cross
s underline for s underline being a pro
finite set which i described earlier
so you can get these awesome products
and um this is
this is the new like model that i use to
uh write um this cool paper with my
awesome colleague robert pretner
about a new model of consciousness where
it's like okay
this is what's going on you know you
have profiling many copies of this of
a perception it's you're not really
perceiving
so um but that that's pretty deep that's
the some of the hardest math on the
planet it's like looking at sheaves
on um a category so discretized time
right so something i came up with just a
bit ago was like there you know there
really is no
you can't really say a equals b whatever
you want to say that
really what you're saying is a equals b
up to some condition
x where x is what is called a homotopy
type
so type theory is like uh pretty rampant
in the
in like um lots of like awesome models
and so a homotopic type is going to be
like it's an equivalence
it's an equivalence um based on
homotopies which are deformations
between two spaces so you can say a is
equivalent to b if criterion x
is considered so you have to be really
careful with the statement equals
yeah and so really we really only have
intersubjective agreement on certain
metrics so i really think there is no
equality for anything
you just have a bunch of agents agreeing
on these metrics right um
the brilliant don hoffman has a bunch of
work on that too and um
i was working in his uh research group
for a bit so you know i think that
mentation these biological processes i
just give a
um a talk on like mentation and
a certain homotopy type um that it
actually works in discrete time so how
are you actually going to do that
how can you actually model memory and
biological functions
over a discretized time that looks like
a bunch of dots so that looks like
memory of a singular support and you're
going to have to
really figure out how you could get
words and things like that
so what i'm going to do is like
introduce those chromatic types
so again there's no personal identity
over time i think you only have
chromatic towers of localization i'll go
over that
but in your singular support you're
doing what's called a localization
localization is a way of adding
inverses um you know for instance the
integers right
if you want to add like inverses to the
integers you need to get something like
the rational numbers
so to add inverses is a way of making a
space more
full i'll say and then also you can take
categories
which have morphisms and you can make
the morphisms isomorphism which means
they're invertible
so localization's pretty powerful so
again there really is no personal
identity uh you know there's only
personal identity
up to time i also think i don't know
time may be just the up to condition for
you to exist
you are in essence localizing at each
point of the singular supports
and i think i wrote yeah i've wrote a
little paper about this that should be
out in the journal
cognitive science so hopefully it's
there so what is this
so homotopy type is a topological space
regarded up to weak
homotopia equivalence um uh what okay
so it's a topological space regarded up
to um you know
uh how you know um how you can actually
equate various objects in the space and
what's called an infinity groupoid um
you know you can get an
infinity groupoid where all the
morphisms are actually
so all the maps are actually invertible
so we call a weak homotopia equivalents
a map between topological spaces which
induces
isomorphisms on all the homotopic groups
the homotropic groups are encoding
um the homotopy behavior and so
say that's in that book that i
recommended to you
so groups so we're familiar with groups
you know that you know where symmetries
relate an object to itself
and but a group void you have symmetries
acting between more than one object as
you can see in this like
this visual so i've got a b c d these
are multiple objects and you have maps
going everywhere
so um a groupoid is a category where all
the morphisms are isomorphisms
so if i have an infinity groupoid it
means i have an infin infinite
morphisms so infinite isomorphisms so
the big idea for the chromatic type is
to actually put a chromatic tower
over a temporal logic we're all familiar
with temporal logic
and you're going to see what i mean by
this tower so i think you can actually
create
chromatic types instead of a homotopy
type
so we're going to be interested in
creating these chromatic spaces
that have their own notion of
localization
and then you can get a new idea of time
so localizing a geometric homotopic so
again i told you localization is a way
of adding
inverses in category theory that means
you want to make your maps
isomorphisms so we say given a category
c in a class w of morphisms we seek the
localization
c w inverse you can get a reflective
what you do is you localize which means
add inverses you complete the space
what if that's a koshi space like if you
want to get sequences to converge
and then you take the inverse limit
which is gluing you're going to see i do
a lot of gluing
so for a category a category is a
collection of objects and morphisms and
you have an associativity condition and
an identity arrow
so homotopies again are maps ways to get
ways to get objects to be equivalents
and there's all kinds of ways that you
can do that so i'm interested in
something called topological
localization so this is another
type of topic localization so we say a
topological localization is a left exact
localization and again i'm going to go
very gentle with some of these
definitions
left exact localization of an infinity
one category so that's a category of
infinite morphisms um in the sense of
passing to what's called a reflective
sub infinity one category at a
collection of morphisms that are
monomorphisms
so um with the details are
of course they're important but for uh
the the whole point is that you have a
reflective
subcategory what's that reflective
subcategory it's a full subcategory
such that the objects d and the
morphisms have reflections
in the category so that's very cool so
the objects and the morphisms
have reflections every object in d looks
at its own reflection by a certain
morphism t
d to td and the reflection of an object
c and c is actually equipped with an
isomorphism
so that's great the inclusion creates
all limits and it has all cool limits
which de-admits so
the to say that you have limits and
co-limits means that your category is
sort of a
very very nicely well behaved so this is
very neat
that in the reflective subcategory it
seems very apropos
to pair that with the diamond work that
i'm trying to do because
uh the diamond is dealing with
profinetly made copies of these
reflections
and the reflective subcategory you know
contains
uh reflections of the actual object so
it's a very very special
um subcategory
so again the whole idea is to get okay
so maybe at every moment you are
actually topologically
localizing and so that actually means
you're actually just looking at your own
reflections all the time which you
are right there's a lot of maxims that
say you know you see what you
are absolutely so um i'd still you know
so
i'm using all of that beautiful
mathematics to actually justify a
statement
that you know would only like without
the mathematics the statement would just
be like
a sentence and i can actually try to
justify it structurally
so i think you're actually localizing
time as these kinds of equivalences
so there really is no well-defined
notion of metric you really just have
uh you know why why are we working in
topological spaces because the metrics
are very subjective
and so you work topologically or you
don't really have a notion of metric but
you have a closeness condition
so everyone works topologically and i'm
trying to categorify the notion of time
and space means to throw it into
category theory
let's talk about its morphisms and how
you localize it
and how you invert the morphisms so you
need to ask
huh you know so topological spaces you
have a topology on a space
so here right with the like the diamond
i put it you know like um
you know peter puts a sheath on a you
know in a category like okay
so what are open sets in a category
that's actually not trivial
right like um so you know i say the
construction of the topological
localization seems appropriately meta
in its construction of a reflection of
what is already profinitely many copies
i say the word v stack it's a higher
notion of a diamond
and i'll go into that a little bit later
so the the second meta
question is how would you actually put a
topology like on an infinity one
category
that's hard right you have to actually
figure out what the open sets are
in a category right and so uh basic
point set topology and like anything in
hatcher is going to go over
you know topological spaces and
topologies but to actually get one on a
category that's not so easy
so there is something called an infinity
one site on an infinity one category
it's the data encoding an infinity one
category of infinity one sheaves the
sheaves see the pre-sheaves
inside a certain category of pre-sheaves
um so
um these are just like i said in chris's
talk these are like
ways of monitoring kind of local data
around a space
sheets are attached to certain spaces
and so we call
um a topology on a category of site so
what's this chromatic tower
well the chromatic tower looks like this
so um it's
actually there's a whole bunch of work
on chromatic homotopy theory just
plugging this in
but what is that right it's a way of
identifying spaces using these chromatic
towers
so given this ln this is a boost field
localization of what's called a maraba k
theory so these k theories are ways of
looking at isomorphism classes of vector
bundles
you have a wedge sum there um and
uh so this localization gluing right
localization is adding inverses
um so given that we call the the
homotopy limit over the chromatic tower
so there's a tower of these things
called spectra which are objects that
behave like co homology theories and
chromology theories are
exploring holes in spaces and
just kind of data nice invariants about
space because you want to classify these
spaces
and so you have these towers based on
the levels of spectra
so this is mo this is what i'm uh when i
say the p
localization of a spectrum that's uh
it's pretty detailed but
uh we're saying like it's localized with
respect to a certain p
and so without without like
super going into the details of that you
have uh
towers of equivalences and so based on
your layer
based on where you are on the chromatic
tower
is what you're going is how you're going
to be navigating
so that's memory space to me recall
memory space it's all the same
navigating your touring degree
is is in a sense a chromatic tower like
this so to create a chromatic type
i'm going to make uh equivalences based
on the layers of this tower
so for instance you know if you're on
the top layer making a
an equivalence between the top layer
and uh you know um so replacing
home never replacing but upgrading the
homotopy type
with chromatic type okay
so we say for memories and computability
i said uh again at that mentation talk
that i just gave not too long ago at the
biological conference
what else besides computing might be
involved in biological mentality right
i'm just going a little um
phenomenological so we can pull this
together but you know it's a it's a
homotopic type that could be a chromatic
type
it proceeds by weak equivalences it far
exceeds there's a lot of like expander
graphs and graph theory that model it i
just think it's insufficient
and i think that you can get into these
towers and get a little more
of what's going on so i also say memory
proceeds like an almost apology that's a
very strict word from
faultings uh what it means to be almost
but
we can say that memory has a singular
support like i told you like a cantor
set
and it's what's called a descent
condition in my opinion which is a
gluing
right so memory is recall and it's
putting everything together so you can
actually
localize at this specific instant
whatever that is
and so it behaves more like a descent
condition so again a weak equivalence is
a class of morphisms in a specific
category
computability right so there's a bunch
of uh stuff there's a huge msri awesome
msri conference um
a program um during 2020 about
decidability definability and
computability
so computability right is the ability to
solve a problem in an effective manner
you've got all these calculuses turing
computable
weaker automata stronger hyper
computation i say you know
i think it's the actual ability to to
construct descent conditions so i think
we need to take
these very strict terms about how we
navigate and
categorify them so you see me kind of
adding
like well why don't we upgrade that
upgrade the mathematics used there
um you know define abilities about
structuring knowledge and concept
formation decidability
say binary decision problem is decidable
there is just an effective method for
deriving the correct answer you know
and this it's very uh this is very kind
of um
clearly not you know this is not what i
was giving you in the chromatic tower i
think there's more ways of getting
around
and saying things are actually effective
if you use this sort of weak equivalence
kind
so memory so what else besides
information algorithms are involved in
biological
mentality well a lot you've got
geometric logic girdle and completeness
singular
support right so i call this um in my
paper with robert we come up with a
nested hierarchy
of awarenesses and i'll go over that in
about one second so i call it a oneness
one awareness's capacity to construct
morphisms between
other one awarenesses so we're all
relating consciousness whatever it is is
geometrical and relational i don't think
it's a computational
so you can get this categorical i'm
trying to figure out a way oh
you know we know the notion of turing
degrees let's get a categorical notion
of that
so um you know i say recall
your ability to recall is what's called
a localization sequence this is a
co-fiber sequence
where you have these maps and you have a
condition between functors
and what pops out is a fiber
and so you given so this is what i think
is happening when you actually recall
you look for a certain state
out pops a memory right so there's a
bunch of category theory going on
so what are the fundamental units of
life that's very tricky
right um there's a lot of um i think
there's a story about
like a beautiful monk that went up to a
hill to just um sort of self desiccate
and everyone thought he passed away but
maybe he had one heartbeat a year
so my question is like what what is that
what are the fundamental units
of life could it be that someone slips
under the radar
of what we would call metabolic life but
there's another set of brain waves
that are maybe mirror symmetries on the
other side so like you see i have this
chromatic tower with everything on the
right
side i want to build a what's on the
left side
so all of this i have chromatic towers
with right sides yeah so maybe this is
the condition of life and what if you
reflect it on the other side what does
that even mean
um so again i'm you know playing around
uh
trying to figure out levels of
consciousness so for instance clyde
wearing the famous case
um awesome pianist right super brilliant
pianist um
got an um i think an hpv and got an h
like uh got a retrograde amnesia and so
he's got a seven second memory and he
only has motor memory and no personal
memory
right so you can be like you know he'll
say i've never seen a doctor before in
my life and he's visited by doctors all
the time
so it's very interesting with someone
like that you have to ask the conditions
of what are clive waring's fundamental
units of life
and i literally think what you could you
can more easily categorize what's going
on rather than just saying retrograde
amnesia
maybe some layers in the tower layers in
the chromatic tower have been uh
gone and that's what's happening so if
layers in the chromatic tower are cut
then you actually have uh you know so
just like a geometric way of
interpreting all of this
okay so let's get to discrete time right
so discrete time
why do we model time as continuous like
why
again i think it's an overlook and um i
just think
we haven't focused on it so why do we
model time as a counter or as the
background for some kind of
you know background dependent model
right um what i have pictured here is
what's called a spectral sequence
and so if time looks like these series
of dots inside the dot is encoded a
whole bunch of information about a space
so you could model time as like a
modulized space and that's what i said
um when chris gave us tall right so that
points they're not just points right
they actually encode
other information but you can see that
there are gaps between the points
so if you model time as uh discontinuous
or you know
or discretized um what's actually in
between the gaps so then we say okay
well quantum mechanics model space is a
non-our comedian field
why is time also not not our comedian
why not
so i opened with that question what
would it mean to phenomenologically have
a discrete time what would exist between
like t1 and t2 that's really rich
what's actually there maybe suskin would
say that's the pyramid
emergence right he's got the two black
holes entangled he thinks emergence
comes from the entanglement black hole
so everyone's looking at that
and then you get paternitism and
temporal parts again it tells you where
you exist across
time just like you exist across space so
um
i you know i asked why do we experience
memories is time entangled with memory
where does entanglement end that's my
question
how would memories actually exist in
discrete time that's tricky
that's tricky right so again you have
someone like me who thinks there is no
personal identity over time but yet you
have a memory
right somehow um so anyway so how would
you actually define memories in end time
i don't think there's just one timeline
here
so i put together this theory where i
think you have
the the levels of time you have is
depending on the levels of category that
you are and so i'm going to go over that
so the levels of time that you are able
to navigate depends on your complexity
class and the level of
uh space that you can actually navigate
so how would we experience memories in
an end time imagine you had n
levels of time in a tower so uh with
roberts and our pluralist manus paper
and also the perfecto diamond paper
right we'd say you know awareness
is a it's i we can do it
representationally say it's a
representation of a pneuma non but we
also want to throw consciousness
into levels and layers
so right here you have a basic notion of
a one category where i have
objects and i have morphisms between
objects that's it
so one category is contains objects and
one
morphism so just a quick category theory
like um category is beautiful and i
cannot do it justice in two seconds but
i'm given just a little recap of what we
need
in the middle here you see a two
category two category contains
objects one morphisms and what we call
two morphism so two morphisms or
morphisms
between the morphisms you see i have a
map here from f1 to g2 so this fee
and you see i have a gamma here from f2
to g1
so that's this is getting what i think's
right so
basic basic complexity class can only oh
hi daniel hi sarah we have an
interaction that's
it right but super precogs or anyone
with total recall like me
i can put a map between this interaction
in this interaction this is what i'm
talking about
a three category three category looks
like this you have objects you have
morphisms between the objects
you have morphisms between the one
morphisms
and you have a three morphism which is a
morphism between the two morphisms you
can see this
f2 going this way right so this is what
i'm saying right depending on your level
of category your level of awareness if
you are a
three awareness creature you're able to
to
navigate this way and so that's why i
said so
if you're a three awareness creature you
live in three time
if you're a one awareness creature you
live in one time um
and again i just i just went on to this
because people like me are either
haunted by
you know sad memories or blessed by
amazing memories and time
for me did not seem to go linearly it
goes like this so we have this first
subjective experience we have this
nested categories of representation
you've got a one awareness
you've got a two awareness so that means
a category of categories of
representation the three awareness
a category of category of categories of
representation
in awareness is our top a categories of
categories of categories
so you can see that what what what does
this sort of correspond to is like well
me giving you this awesome presentation
being welcome
in your environment and uh us also
you know uh being at the cambridge
apostles and having like
tea you know so not just being able to
imagine something like that but being
able to partition your brain
and split your consciousness and to
actually be able to do that
so i'm all i'm really excited about
splitting consciousness and trying to
physically be in multiple places because
i don't think
i don't think there's only one timeline
here but to split consciousness you'd
have to be able to do this in the brain
you know um which is cool so we come up
with so along with in time
and so again you can see that with the
mathematics you're able to do a lot of
stuff here
so within time i came up with this so
you know what i think according to end
time you'd have a pro finite language
like what is that well if you you know
any dairy dog piece or anything
like a in his of hermetology it's going
to show you that the the glossomatics or
the gloss seems you know your
fundamental units of language if you
open them up there's not a lot there
but actually the process of reading is a
trace it's a wild phenomena
because you're pulling together uh so
many pieces so we actually uh i came up
with this awesome language scheme that
was like well
you know uh in in the one space you just
have your normal i
we you know uh me my mine
but in n2 you'd have like a one eye a
two eyes this is if you're in two
awareness right if you're in the two
category
then you would have actually like a one
eye a two eye a one me a two me if
you're in a three category
you'd have a one eye a two eye a three
eye a one me a two me
so instead of just she her there'd be
like three she
three her and i think that's the level
of intricacy in the new language
so getting to some of the physics stuff
and uh going into the emergent time
um so i came up with this uh idea for a
perfecto dictionary again perfectoid
spaces or peter schultz's brilliant work
and i just think it's amazing
and uh so i do think uh quantum physics
needs to be a little revolutionized by
replacing hilbert's space
for the perfectoid space replacing state
vectors the geometric points and i just
gave this a talk at
ucla's ipam entropy conference not too
long ago and i think it was pretty well
received
replace the tensor product with the
diamond product placed non-locality with
the profinet and many copies of spa c
replace superposition with these
pro-ital sheaves and pro-finite sets
the collapse of the wave function was
such so tricky uh replace it with a
what's called a tilting operation which
takes us from characteristic zero to
characteristic p
you get these also perfectoid modular
curves replace
upgrade the holographic principle with
the six functor formalism
which is a groth and deconstruction and
i'm about to show you that
you can replace quantum topology upgrade
it with this a tell commonology
replace operator out again it's great
but you can just upgrade stuff so i
shouldn't say replace but upgrade
let's let's let's uh let's replace
operator algebra with a non-therian
uh version and unitarity with a
a certain descent data so you have this
uh this is uh
peter's um um six functor formalism
where
in a six functor formalism it is a way
of making a theory i would say really
um it's um uh it's a a
a notion of um replacing
poincare uh normal point correct duality
with abelian chief comology and it's
something called verdier duality so
there's dualities going on here which is
why i thought it'd be great
to pair it with the holographic
principle because the holographic
principle is
really fortified by juan maldocina's ads
cft
proposed duality between you know uh um
like the gauge gravity duality so you
have this uh
fmfk theory thing that i'm working on of
a diamond and you have these
uh the six operations and so with these
six operations these are just image
functors between
sheaves and um you get this notion this
is what i'm thinking of
so uh in quantum gravity right you have
the holographic principle and it's still
very kind of loosely
um defined and it's it's it's a given
and only a negative
condition like defined by what it's not
and so i think the holographic principle
instead of having um
ads you know anti-sitter space in the
middle and the conformal field theory in
the bulk that you could actually have
the six functor formalism in the middle
and the profinitely many copies like the
diamonds um
looking like the conformal field theorem
this is what i'm working on right now
so emergent time um so these v stacks
these are
higher dimensional diamonds and so
they're certainly holographic
uh in a sense that they encode already
profoundly many copies of data that's
already multiple on two fronts
so um a v stack is a two sheaf so this
is like you know the sheaths that hold
you in cold
encode local data so this now it's it's
a
it's one category up uh it takes values
in categories rather than
sets so you know you're going to have to
shift to v stack if you want to do uh
this profiling language
so um here's a conjecture with chris and
i you know we're trying to generalize
the distinction between
separable and entangled this is not easy
um so
once again recall that the geometric
points in the diamond amorphism of
schemes there's something called a
bearwise silicon
and infomorphism and this is an adjoint
pair
um and so okay so you have an adjoint
pair these are sort of like
inverses like inverse functions uh but
they're um
functors and so we extend this idea to
the two adjoint pairs
um this is f upper star um rf
uh lower star for the derived category
and then f lower shriek and f upper
shriek shriek is a
kind of slang for the punctuation so
those are referring to once again the
peter's operations so that's the grand
correspondence right is going to be this
um this derived category which consists
precisely of the atel
sheaves of these certain modules for a
small diamond
okay so let's get to emergent time so
how what am i i'm gonna use all this how
do i actually
pull this together so if you consider
the simplest case we say an event
what is an event it's a i'm going to
call it a topological localization of
any particular reference frame
right event is normally like i don't
know simultaneity or says something like
that
try not to use the word simultaneity so
we'll say a topological localization of
somebody's reference frame
let's consider that to be a point in the
diamond topological space on that point
is a certain site i told you right
that's how you're going to get a
topology
we're going to call this site the pro
hotel site the category of pro finite
sets
s so this is from
more of peter's work on condensed
mathematics so global time emerges as a
set of continuous maps from all pro
finite sets
s to t so again you have these chopped
up notions of time and you can get
global time to emerge as the
set of continuous maps from again the
all the pro finite cantor sets
back to t back to the topological space
so global time could be considered as a
sheaf of sets on this pro hotel site
and that's called a condensed set based
on his work with uh um
clausen so emergent time results in
passing to the larger category of she's
to consider a condensed version of this
is an f theory construction i don't want
to go over too much it's a little deep
so a second conjectural way to get an
emergent time you can actually
use diamonds and take equivalence
relations of those to actually get uh
the v stacks so again when i showed you
the definition of diamond you
took um equivalence relations of you to
protel equivalence relations
well let's upgrade and you can take
actually equivalence relations of
diamonds to get modulized spaces of v
stacks
that's pretty big so there's new work
being done about how do you actually you
know
how about a new algebra this is peter
and dustin's new work how do you do
algebra and
rings and modules carry a topology i
think this stuff is great
and this is where i'm at it's like hey
we need to like
rev up mathematics you need to upgrade
to some physics stuff and i think
um we can all learn from it so if you
can turn functional analysis into a
branch of commutative algebra
that's very nice build a version of
algebraic geometry allows rings
of convergent power series as basic
building blocks because my question is
how do you actually do analysis
in non-archimedean geometry right that's
actually kind of tricky
and exciting for a mathematician right
so you want to put some kind of
completeness condition on modules
you know which are like they mimic
vector spaces but
uh the scalars are not fields they can
come from the rings
the coefficients of the rings and so in
such a way that the free objects behave
like some kind of power series instead
okay so you can construct algebraic
geometry you can start with an abelian
category of abelian groups you have a
tensor product which is just a way of
organizing
and then you can consider rings in this
sort of category you can associate
spec r with the same spa r that i showed
you in the diamond
and basics and open subsets can
correspond to localization so look how
cool this is you're using localizations
to define what an open subset is you
include these spec r's together along
these open subsets you can form these
schemes
and accordingly the category of our
modules glues to form the category quasi
coherence sheets
so again this is all uh peter's
construction i think it's great how do
you construct analytic geometry we'll do
the same thing
um but topological abelian groups don't
form an abelian category
i'll just go over this you can use the
his notion of condensed mathematics
to make it make things a little better
you can replace topological groups
with these condensed sets so here's the
whole point so
um this definition right the protel site
of a point is the category of pro finite
sets so these are cantor sets
ish uh with finite jointly subjective
families of maps as covers
so we say a condensed set is a sheaf of
sets on the pro-ital site
so again we're working pro-finite and
pro-atel because of the diamond
condition
so similarly a condensed group group um
ring whatever um on the protel site is
called that
you can put a category together condense
of condensed objects
so this means that this whole thing is a
functor so you can get a functor from
certain categories
and that's fine i don't want to go into
this too too much
so given a condensed set you can refer
to t star as its underlining set
so there's a canonical example that
illustrates um
how you would actually change to um
from a topological space so let t be a
topological space
to t there's associated a condensed set
t bar
and that's defined by sending any
profinite set to the set of continuous
maps from s to t
this satisfies both properties um it
means that for any map
for which the composite is continuous
it's continuous
so t underlined is a condensed um uh
this pro finite set
um yeah so why like why are we using all
this pro finite condition well because
once again
it's in the language i don't want to get
lost in the details so it's in the
language
right it's in the awareness the level of
awareness that you are
right dictates your whole complexity
class
so if and again if these spaces are pro
finite spaces
right then you need to make sure that uh
what do we mean when we say localize we
need to make sure we know what the open
subsets are
and that's why i was using like the
pro-itel site there's you know that's
just one idea there's
lots of ideas how you could model this
but the main takeaway
that i want you know to kind of leave
everybody with is like okay
so what are memories like there is no
synchronous reference how are we
actually
getting through time yeah if every point
is discretized
you must be getting through time uh you
know through
your localization but i'm trying to try
to upgrade the consciousness level and
go well
you know i think you can actually
upgrade the level of awareness if you
can start thinking in terms of morphisms
and
uh morphisms between morphisms so um
you get the emergent time phenomena by
using the pro-ital site
and then you get the diamond holographic
principle by using the
six operations and the profinitely many
copies like that
so uh once again you get the chromatic
types from looking at these towers of
localization
and you can put this over a temporal
logic to maybe to maybe
you know figure out what's going on with
clive wearing once again like where is
the meaning in that
um yeah okay so i put up some of my
references and i think i will just
stop there
awesome thank you so much
maybe you can unshare and then we'll
be really happy to ask you some
questions here to learn more
all right sarah maybe take it away yeah
so
so that was a great brain scramble um
like i guess i'm wondering actually this
really comes directly from
philosophy before i went on this um live
stream
i was looking at just where topology
fits into philosophy by way of this
standard
insight or stanford encyclopedia and um
one thing that stood out to me was was
modal logic
um and i found myself asking you know
with all of these new um
topologies or set theory or however you
want to do it like
we always kind of run into this tension
between these
really complicated
homeomorphic whatever kind of morphic
you know our ability to conceptualize
these morphisms
and our ability to like make use of them
like
or you know and we make these really
complicated math constructs
and then but at some point we have to
communicate with each other and so
i'm kind of wondering with any math
construct and like
maybe even specifically yours like how
do you see the construct
converging like looping back you know
conceptually such that it doesn't just
run away from you know from us in our
ability to understand
yeah so well that's why i said so for me
uh thinking
like those constructs are not difficult
i would say the communicating part is
the difficult part
you know like i mean but you should
watch children they're all over the
place
right i think i think you're here to
imagine
and that you actually i'm like a super
synesthete so for somebody like me
right i just rattled that off and you
saw that that was probably the easiest
thing for me but asking me to maybe
replace
like a cartridge in an ink like a
printer
that might be really difficult for me so
it's interesting that when you say
um how do we not lose it
so i think and that's what i was saying
i think it depends on where your brain
thrives like somebody like me i love the
font of like oh yeah i'm definitely a
three awareness
i want to think about morphisms between
morphisms and morphisms
and so i actually don't think they're
difficult
i think you you know it's something like
it's just a it's just a math is just
another language
you know and if you're a person that
like likes learning new languages i
think
there is no difficulty around it and so
i don't think i
for me i don't think there's anything
hindering it because i think what's
worse
is to leave it in a word statement if
you didn't have that math justifying it
you would just have a sentence saying
uh what like the world is unknowable
or something like that right so i
actually think you're just kind of
displacing
displacing you know you're doing physics
physics is totally hard
right you know like okay but let's say
for example because in moto logic they
were just talking about
knowing versus assuming versus you know
so they had these kind of conjunctive
sections in a sentence and it's i mean i
i don't know i think language is
actually the hard thing and actually
making math
hook into language in such a way that we
can actually communicate without
exhausting each other you know like
actually make the make the information
transfer um is not you know once you go
from like believing
to assuming you get all these funky like
um you know predicates or you get all
these funky like um contingencies
and so actually having math such you
know that that works with all of these
subtleties is like
i don't know anyway that's that's where
i'm coming from is like how do you get a
math that doesn't
that doesn't get like pumped by language
that's funny yeah but isn't it exciting
because you didn't know much about
topology until i said it right
but you're on an exploration and you're
learning more
so i don't think it's actually
detracting at all right like
no no i'm not necessarily detracting i'm
saying um
facilitate help like compressing
compressing language you know
compressing concepts
right and i think on my end i'm not i i
think that's
might be deleterious i think it might be
open them
open all the concepts what's uh you know
i don't think time exists anyway so it's
like what what's the rush right
i'm just fine all right so you know what
i mean
and one note on that is um the linear
strings
spoken or podcast or live stream or text
right they're often ill-specified but
also it it enforces
a so-called temporal structure a local
syntactic in a semantic structure
and um whether one chooses to see these
these um associations as
foundational like the roots that this is
growing out of
like the previous literature threads is
it running off away into the dark forest
of the literature or is it actually
anchoring
in vast bodies of knowledge so really
interesting this
discussion oh yeah see that's a dance
talk so
how cool that uh what's natural for me
is like math and literary right so
you've got
some heavy philosophers that were onto
some great things and i'm like hey why
don't we just
fortify what they're saying with uh some
diagrams and you see it's easy if i
say oh maybe clive waring's chromatic
tower is cut
that in a certain way like the math part
there is actually
while there is a steep learning curve
you're able to actually get inside of
clive wearing in a way that you're not
in a way that just like daniel's saying
um you know retrograde amnesia okay
great that's a linear word
you need a sentence you actually need to
go into that
what is that and so i actually think
language
is um deceiving if it's actually too
compressed
and if it's actually not transparent
there's a beautiful transparency in
mathematics
it's all there you know and again math
is not perfect either right there's
what is a point we have some serious
problems you know you've got
you've got predicative and then you know
how many definitions in math or
self-referencing is horrible
you know so like math is not to be
worshipped at all and that's why it's
like oh
we should just have all the languages
you can see i talk about everything at
once and i'm like
but that's my synesthete right i think
there's actually the
the beautiful thing about the synesthete
is that maybe you can see
uh like an aerial view of things and i
think for me
i can do a local global just because of
the way my brain works
you know but then i was you know i was
trying because i love everybody's like
differences and i don't want anybody to
be like anybody else and i was trying to
say
like hmm it seems that you know maybe
sometimes we're one awarenesses and
sometimes we're 12 awarenesses
but i really i'm really interested in
why
um like i don't know how you two are but
if like if you have total recall
like or memories like have you ever had
memories just come in or future memories
or deja vu
i'm really interested in stuff like that
yeah i just wanted to clarify the the
compression thing though i want to
defend compression for a minute
normally i would agree you know like the
the connotation with that i'm like no
that's
bad you throw away a lot of nice
subtleties but i've definitely
felt um in my limited experience with
philosophy i've definitely bumped up
against
um some spots where there have been
words that if you know somebody once
somebody
hits it when somebody puts a noun to a
concept to a word
it's like this fantastic compression
algorithm where it's like oh that's a
concept
somebody had and they put it into a word
and now i can pack it up and
like make some more space in my brain
for other stuff and
i think that is like bad practice
whether it can be in math or or
in words like in whatever mean means you
do
it's it's just it's the best so i'm
always now i'm finding myself like
looking for that for that ratchet you
know and you would love well then you
would love math but it's like then
because it's all symbols right but i'm
just saying yeah
i guess i don't see it compressing it
doesn't have this at least not for my
brain like i can't
i can't like it doesn't package
something up so i can make more space
for other things
but it but it does because it's like oh
there's a tower so you can just keep the
tower in your brain and not the 800
pages that got there
just like when somebody puts a noun on a
concept like anti-sitter space
um i think yeah i mean for me it would
be i would be deceiving myself to think
i'm just storing the word you're not
you're storing all the physics
and everything in them you know what do
you what do you think about that um
right
you know this nesting is a topic that
comes up a lot so we talk about nested
markov decision processes how within the
active inference model just
only looking at the mathematics within
this one little clade of math
you can nest those models but then
there's also nesting that's
based upon category theory not my area
but it seems like there's very nuanced
ways of doing
nesting and relationships and so what i
heard with this discussion around
like a sort of a whole total system
shift
upgrade with a dictionary it's like
synergetics and bucky fuller
in that if you understand the interfaces
interfaces between
what these things are currently doing in
the system you can
take them out and like hot swap them
it's like okay it's a graphics card
we could make it a different graphics
card or we could have the same interface
and then improve what's on the other
side of the interface and then it turns
out to be really meta because we're
working on active inference
which is in a way the theory about how
the interfaces work and definitely in
the active inference lab we're taking
a different um approach but it's like
mount everest because
we're you know meeting at different base
camps together
to talk with people who have different
perspectives
yeah yeah which is but that's where
everything thrives is in the
intersections
right so that's yeah it's like look how
much stronger math is when you hit it
with philosophy
also vice versa or any of this stuff or
any of the bio
right upgrade retrograde amnesia to a
chromatic tower and it's like whoa
you know so i think i think nothing is
lost in the intersection then what did
you say earlier about
uh what bucky called emergence you said
something cool
uh emergence through emergency
yeah yeah and his emergency like the uh
every time i like survival or
like what to actually connect that's
what you said about your uh
string of natural language being
effortless
in active inference we think about how
the action is following
in some sense actually on a geodesic a
path of least resistance
like the chemical reaction even if it
releases a lot of heat and light
in the context that it's in it actually
is the most probable thing or the most
energy releasing thing the free energy
is negative and so it dissipates
and um understanding how that
dissipation can be
brought into the informational regime
with semantic flow and like a delta g
for for semantic information rather than
just syntax or even chemistry
that's about this mapping of mappings
with free energy as a nomadic concept in
a way or a nexus
that we connect the free energy in the
chemical we develop certain experiments
maybe unique predictions
and then by building the math that's
general enough
to interface nicely we actually we nest
the concepts
so that we can deal with the nested
systems that are more syntactic at the
lower level
going down into the quantum and then
more semantic at the higher level
into the teleological good yeah and then
the semantic at the higher level right
then you can invoke a homotopic type
chromatic type and then you can actually
you know uh all the types are nomatic as
well so i like that right
nothing is until it actually like
spreads so i also think
you know it's it's a false conception of
movement
if you actually think you know if you
don't start from the middle and spread
you know hey shayna can we
um i wonder if we can anchor some some
some exploration
around uh one of your questions it's on
the list
yeah um so like but i don't remember
what they are
and it might be too much of a technical
hassle to post them so if you could like
pick
one of the questions that you're
bringing up
yeah let me just share again and then
you tell me which one you like okay okay
this will be like the uh who wants to be
a millionaire
of right this is cool yeah
who wants to be the millionaire back to
the principle should we should we do a
quick
random number generator no pick one
yeah just look at a few and then let's
anchor them and then go
wild whatever one okay so so actually
now
this helps trip my memory so and then
don't forget i have these two
so pick which one maybe i can like make
it
can you see that yeah i can't um
this is something i've been tripping out
on a bit
so and see so measurement
2-2
yeah no i know where it is um i thought
i might pick a second one but
um that's definitely should i go with
that and then you bring it down or do
you want it
let's go let me unshallow i can see
y'all's lovely places
okay we're saying what is it what is
measurement right yeah go for it yeah
yeah well um i
i tend to take a lot of these i
i'm finding that i have a attraction to
taking a lot of these questions and
putting them in some embodied form that
seems to be
i don't know how i'm going to do that in
a thesis in such a way that i actually
graduate but
um this is it's really interesting to me
i
i um you know we have
affordances we have tools and all these
other things these kind of prosthetics
that allow us to make sense of the world
but i
i really just think of them as
prosthetics and in a sense we're
we're um making sense of the world by
feeling
and and i mean feeling in the the one
sense of like feeling
you know whether or not that actually
relates to emotions that's another
really interesting question but
um to be conservative you know i'm just
talking about feeling like our tactile
sense and then we use
all these affordances to augment our
tactical sense
but so it's really interesting to think
about like
all this objective measurement in
science and whatnot
and how that's actually related to to
our embodied
like it won't be true to us at some
level unless we can makes out of it to
make sense out of it at an embodied
level
so that's is that that's as there was
another kind of hook i had in philosophy
but
um i can't really remember what it is
right now but that's something that's
alive for me so i don't know if you have
any thoughts about it
yeah well i'm like super impact too
right so uh
to you know i i'm going to dissociate
the emotional
from the irrational like i don't believe
in that and uh they both
are equally there right the rationality
is like the
emotional uh guidance system so yeah
when i say
like when i say what is a measurement
i'm just saying there's a lot
that goes into that that says you know
this is the fixed speed of light
and this is the this and so measurement
seems like it only holds
up to a certain condition right this is
the this is the speed of light until i
change your ambient space
right if you lived on a taurus or if you
lived on a klein bottle if you lived on
something else
i promise you you'd have a different
speed of light because that's just the
illumination problem in mathematics
given a strange space right and i put a
point source in it
what uh if you trace out all the rays
right well
every point in the actual shape be hit
not really it won't if you have a very
complicated space so
for uh for me how far how far does the
measurement
hold and metrics again since i'm such a
fan of like
topology and sheaves and things like
this the metric
seems like it is uh not substantial
right it is it is based on like i said
inter-subjective agreement among agents
so when you say um you know like
i i yeah i'm not sure if your question
is like is it objective or subjective i
think all measurements here are
subjective
right uh and so also here's an actual
problem in the measurement if you're
like strict copenhagenist and stuff like
that
right so um nothing should quote exist
right if everything is in its free form
of superposition
what does it actually mean to measure
something without like actually limiting
the thing
and who's the measurement for if you
crush the superposition
into like one state i've measured it
right
i don't know what that means and i also
think that the minute all your observers
go away
the the thing that was measured goes
back into its original state
so that's why i said like what is a
measurement and chris and i are always
talking about this
right that that assumes that you are
somehow independent of the thing that
you're measuring
and i don't know how to actually do that
right i don't really know what a
boundary is because if you zoom into
your arm
we could take like an electron
transmission microscope and i'd be able
to zoom into your arm in like two
seconds so where'd the boundary go
you know where is the boundary and that
i i'm i'm very perplexed because the
boundary in mathematics is like some
kind of
asymptote right what is an acid like you
know so are you dealing with sort of uh
asymptotes and that's that's what we're
calling a measurement
you know you're like a bus is this long
true until i subject the bus to a lot of
time or i
pour gasoline on the bus and burn it you
know what i mean so how long does the
measurement hold you know yeah i like
that so
so you're yeah so i i hadn't thought
about so much about context and feeling
i was definitely like
it's a fixed thing so that's that's
useful to think about not really like
fixed according to whom fixed for that
second but
like yeah everything is in free fall and
like you see
um i really think there is nothing
periodic here i think there is no
repetition
right we have to actually account for
like what leap year or something right
because the calendar is off
so i'm i'm really uh i'm really
impressed that in
our like in everybody's free fall and
you know what the earth is
going a thousand miles an hour east
right and that if everything is rotating
your own cells are popping in and out
where is the measurement i'm not sure
nothing is fixed
so it's very silly to think that i have
this measurement it's like if you only
knew
that you were actually working over
discrete time
in that moment the moment that you were
measuring the bus is no longer there
right so that's what i'm very very
interested in
i measured the bus five minutes ago but
is it the same bus
no and i don't know what that means so
that's what like what are you actually
measuring we could measure profanity
many copies of the thing
but you need to say that the measurement
is of the reflection of the thing
and that's that's the one thing i do
like about the temporal parts work is
that the bus
yesterday is it really the bus today
i don't know and i've always been i've
always been perplexed that you know you
wake up to the same space
but do you really i'm not really sure
and so um that's
you know uh boundaries i'm really
interested in boundaries and like how
they actually uh
how they work because i'm not really
sure they do i mean clearly like i can
hit my hand on a
on the on the glass but that's just
that's at this scale
right if i so i'm just saying that a
measurement
if you're going to say a measurement
then you need to be real precise about
uh there's no time involved there's no
this involved it's only at an instant
boom this measurement holds at an
instant because tomorrow who knows
and what's up with the measuring stick
like there's so many uh like quantum
mechanically the meteor stick doesn't
exist anyway
so so i don't even know how to use all
these freaking
philosophical labels but i want to ask
if your ambition in
in trying to apply uh topology a kind of
a paradigm
is to arrive at some form of realism or
are you
interested in i mean i'm kind of
wondering what your ground is in terms
of like
yeah what would be the what's the end
goal
in terms of like what would be the
perfect math in your mind like where
would it take you
right yeah well i'm after those grain
unified theories right so i'm after the
i'm after the unifying the grand unified
theories of physics with the grain
unified theories of math because i
actually think
the math one encompasses the physics
that's why you see me going hey
why don't we look at like a number
theoretic version of a black hole
something like that
because i think that in the grand
unified theories of math
i'm gonna get everything because i'm a
super tech mark like
uh level four but you're gonna you're
gonna get everything you're gonna get
you're gonna ever what are you gonna get
oh yeah well that's why i said like oh
well are you calling reality like just
this little glip you got to remember
that i believe in like
in consciousness right so my goal is to
actually partition
the brain partition the consciousness so
that you can actually experience
everything at once again i don't believe
in linear time i don't think it goes
linearly
and i'm really baffled why the brain
only does that
and i think it does not because i know
when you're freshly formed like
um a baby it's very it's such a
beautiful being because
you know she's like a little portal i'm
like where did you come from
you know like the very act of birth is
something interesting because it seems
like it's something that got through the
interface
right where did this little portal come
from and i'm actually
i'm not so interested in the mechanics
of the interface i'm interested in
breaking through the interface taking
off the interface and trying another one
because again i think that the 20
fundamental numbers and everything that
you're subjected to here
and the laws of physics or whatever are
just purely interface-based which i
which i think is a mathematics concept
it would be so rad if we were all able
to take off the interface of this
complexity
of our current complexity and quote go
somewhere else
i don't mean milky way i don't mean that
i mean leave this interface all together
of three times of three space and one
time
and go find a different modulized space
right and that's what i'm trying to do
with i'm like oh if you could actually
partition
consciousness right because it seems
like i don't know if y'all had like
general anesthesias or like
if you've ever fainted or anything um i
have a like a few times just from like
kind of intense things but
i remember something remained
it's like you might have wiped out the
consciousness by general anesthesia
right but you didn't take away the
awareness and that's what i was very
curious about
that something was still there and so uh
you know don hoffman and like me it's
like
i'm actually interested in what that
space is right
the kind of talky sensory thing like i
can see that as an apparatus
but i'm sorry i'm interested in like the
divinity whatever the infinity not in a
religious sense but like
what actually transcends this because i
don't think anything here is like real
at all
you know so when people say what's your
baseline reality well it's not this
i'm really always curious to get in the
dream space i'm really always curious
to quote sleep because when i'm asleep
who's asleep
oh your body is not a sleeve right
because you would you know die
so i'm really curious in the states that
are actually
i guess i could say it like this i'm
trying to take subjectivity
out of the interface and put it in a
different setting
i'm not going to have subjectivity
limited by just what the body can do
because there's a lot of pain a lot of
pain keeps people
in the body when i think you could
actually be like someone else you know
so if you could take subjectivity on its
own exploration
which is what i think mathematics is
really good about doing like if i can
have
you know uh people like oh let's think
about simultaneous like
what if you know what if we were
actually here and also
you know at a cambridge apostle meeting
that baffles people
because you know you have this
imagination right we're able to talk and
you're you know i can say
oh sarah david let's imagine like we're
in hawaii swimming with the you know the
sea turtles
you can go there just like that what is
that why can you do that
what is that imaginary space so i
actually think we're actually
really gifted creatures and you have
this beautiful tool
called the imagination which has not
been fortified
so what i'm trying to do is actually put
the imagination
in its own little hogwarts school right
like when you're young you're able to do
plays and you're doing all those things
then you go up and it's like taxes and
like that
and it's like no i actually think we're
here to be creative and you can see all
the philosophers that i like are
vitalists
right and so i think being is creation
so you can see that i'm here to i think
we're here to create new
theories and to break through the
interface now that
i'm not saying people go jump in front
of buses that's not what i'm saying
right i'm saying
it'd be cool to peek through it just
sort of like
how a new baby arrives i am perplexed at
birth nobody can explain it
and you have no idea like how something
broke through um
yeah the interface so where i'm after
with that you see i'm using
uh very beautiful mathematics
i think i think life is very sacred and
very beautiful and it should be
um supported and and uh explained
by an equally sophisticated mathematical
structure so i don't really abide by
this the simplest version is the best
i don't know about that i actually think
that what is what is sophisticated
philosophically should be equally
matched in sophistication mathematically
and then you get a synergy and a harmony
and actually
then you can actually explain a grain
unified theory
because i really think uh i you know if
everything
is a diamond which i really think it is
you know there's a lot of
i think if this reality is like a
modular space of diamonds then i can
just easily jump to a new modulized
space
it's not that difficult you know i don't
know if that sounds like you're like
who's this little per oh yeah i'm
i'm totally like an explorer i'd be like
let's jump in the consciousness bus and
go look at stuff
because it's not just this it's not just
what is i'm you know
your awareness never leaves and it's
awesome to kind of
enter that space you know and actually
like
bring it here you know if you can
actually bring the consciousness space
to here then you're actually more
synesthetic i think you know
uh yeah because i i don't know where one
skill ends and the brain seems to be
you know a hologram itself so when
everything when your central processor
is a hologram
it makes me really curious about what
this space is
you know
i definitely don't think the brain is
like this you know of course you don't
want to get hit in the head
obviously but it's freaky ability to
rewrite
right it's like a super hamming codes
you've got like air correcting code in
the brain obviously to keep the organism
alive
you know but um i i think you know to
come up with like a
you know you know like the riemann zeta
function as a black hole like that's
cool
so i'm just kind of trying to upgrade uh
you know find what is the essence of
things and it's like oh is it math what
is this
you know ah the essence
i'll ask one question which is how how
would you imagine
that this insight or this set of
upgrades potentially being taught to
advanced or younger
students could change research or
practice because i noticed words like
descent condition definability
decidability
completeness of course so where do the
sort of everyday usages of these terms
come into play with how we can rethink
them based upon a new level of
mathematical rigor
oh that's such a great question yeah i'm
such an advocate for like new models of
pedagogy
right because i think the way
mathematics is taught now is horrible
and it makes you know everyone uh
frightened it's like you're taught
calculus first
before logic before topology
before any of it right and so it seems
like
you know you there people are not using
the apostle book that should be the only
book used for calculus
um yeah so if you actually if you taught
a category theory straight you know from
the bottom up
imagine the beautiful connections that
would be able to be made
cross-disciplinary you can see that one
of my main goals is to get people to
talk with each other
get the mathematicians to talk with the
physicists to talk with the philosophers
um you know i think through category
theory you would naturally embody this
synesthetic thinking which is what i'm
trying to be an advocate for
because there's people like non-linear
thinkers like me that can be easily
shunned and didn't say well she works at
the intersection she's not you know
serious about the one topic and i'm like
but the one topic
is a reflection of the other topics when
everything is a diamond
so for me i i see that if you were
introducing these beautiful words like
ah
descent condition and like if you start
from category theory
which is so minimally constructed and
only
and and allows you to add what you need
to build your own space
right you are you are able to
build um um i i would say you're able to
to build in accordance with your own
idea
versus taking another idea and chiseling
it away and adding things artificially
the nice thing about category theory is
that these limits everything is built
into the actual
uh theory itself i'm not starting with
something and adding and then adding and
then adding and then taking away and
being like what is it analysis or is it
like this
so you see there's there's all these
ways and like you know petershaw's
like reconstructing you know uh
functional analysis as commutative
algebra that super sent a seat
because what you're doing is like taking
what you thought was a difference
and you're actually making it the same
thing so i'm such an advocate for
inclusivity and welcoming
so many trains of thought and if
everyone was like oh
hey though that looks like just a
morphism of this and this looks like a
morphism of this
it would actually aid research because
everybody would be working together
you know like can you imagine like new
antidotes and
um you know i'm like a mental health
advocate and uh because um you know
there's been a lot of stuff like
i don't know i'm sure everyone has had
you know elderly family members go
through some you know horrible
neurodegeneration and i am not satisfied
with the way that the brain is being
modeled
and i'm like you know if you actually
were using the morphisms or the
chromatic tower idea
maybe you would be able to understand
what's actually going on in somebody you
know
um and we'd be able to relate to them
empathically
instead of just like this like clear-cut
medicinal thing well they'll never be
good again they lost their memory
well we can you know no i don't think
it's something that can be lost
let's just try to reconstruct the
morphisms you know
so there's like there's so many things
that i'm
after with this one is unifying all
these branches that are working
against each other it's like when the
mathematicians and the physicists
honestly work together right if if they
can
and not have a bunch of egos in the way
then the beauty that results you get
these beautiful
grand unified theories because it's like
we're meant to be inclusive and
everybody to help each other and so
everybody knows that like i'm you know
not an advocate for these like
standardized tests and i'm gonna test
you and i'm better than you
and like i don't know why we test people
to be better than everybody
we could actually be working on things
like this so
i think it like uh it would completely
revolutionize pedagogy and it would
offer
a future model of like what a what a
hogwarts school could look like because
then
you're actually like okay hey we have
the imagination
as a gift it is a gift that you have
this
and so through what i'm trying what i'm
doing here it's like a very
creative take at learning mathematics
and things like that
so then you've actually welcomed into
mathematics
those underrepresented who identify as
creatives
you know i also teach at this art school
and you know they're always like well
i don't have the the best math gifts and
i'm like but look at your visual skills
and in a certain sense they they're
almost the same
you know so i think there's a lot of
beauty like it's like diamonds and
things like this were taught
you know very early or even to all like
a lot of people that you know if you
could integrate this into the research
then you would um i just think there's
beauty and everyone working together i'm
not a very competitive person you know
reminded me of how could you imagine a
way that
uh that art
could actually inform math rather than
the reverse
like not not just art but like improv
improvisation improvisational arts upon
somebody's drawing just free form
and if you could figure out a dynamic
mapping of like oh you're actually
talking about
this this kind of logic and you don't
and you're drawing it but you're not
you're not putting it to you know you
don't even know that you mean that but
you mean that
that is actually kind of fascinating
look how beautiful that is yeah i just
got accepted to what you just said is um
you know i'm an advocate for pedagogy in
the creative settings so
i'll do i'll do uh you know experiments
like that all the time
like their their topic is to design
a four-dimensional university like i
want a four-dimensional university i
want a gymnasium featuring flying
lessons
right and i want a library and um i want
you to talk about adinkras or dinkers or
james gates air correcting codes
these students right have minimal
mathematics skills but they are
in their learning analysis geometry and
topology
to actually make a structure that can
hold flying lessons they're actually
having to teach themselves
a four dimensional coordinate grid
that's not euclidean this is not
euclidean at all it's differential
geometry
right it's bumpy and i said you know
because it's four dimensional and they
only have hyper volumes
so how amazing that you know it's sort
of like um
you know for me it's very sad that it's
only super exclusive like
you know like the exeter academy that
has this harkness method so what i do is
i take the hardness method and i
i speak it everywhere right i teach it
at cal state i teach it here and all
over the place
and um that method of showing
of giving a concept uh synergetically
like that
and showing you know just giving minimal
instruction they're learning math
themselves
and so uh it's like you know i so i'm
interested
in other people who want to experiment
like that you don't learn the chapter
one
this is a triangle you know nobody
learns like that because the way that
you actually learn
uh is to integrate so you know why do
students have so much problem
so many problems solving word problems
because they've been taught these
subjects separately these subjects are
not separate at all
they should be taught integrated in a
holistic manner
and you're totally right sarah the way
to get holistic manner
like um easily digestible is in a
creative way i showed my students like a
um this awesome computer programmer
solving a 4d rubik's cube
i said recreate that and they actually
had oh the four dimension does this oh
it's a test
oh it has that many sides so much easier
than a very linear lesson
this is a four space with uh that you
know i think
i think um uh you know if you're an
intuit like me and most math
comes from this intuition space you need
to honor that intuition space and i
i really think it's shunned so there's
mathematicians like ramanujan and stuff
like that who is saying
i don't know where this idea came from
it just came from this and you know that
can be really shunted
and so but i think a lot of this
visionary stuff
you know comes from um like a
non-specific space
and oh my god i will nurture people's
creative space
look how many ideas come out when you do
some kind of like
fun icebreaker like that right so
anytime i host a conference or something
you know
i you know i'm like uh well you know
imagine we were you know
uh you know alligators you know so i
have people
change the space if you change oh you
know you had claws what would you do
with these claws you know
and so it's like if you can kind of
shake up
you know uh the reel and turn it into
something um
kind of imaginary i think the
imagination is more real
so for somebody like me i privy the
imaginary space because like this pin
i think there was an idea of a pin
before the pin so the pin is okay in my
opinion but i still think the imaginary
space
trumps everything right you had to have
the idea of the car i
want to have the idea of the thing so i
put a lot of my efforts into nurturing
like students imaginary space you know
so oh my god yeah infusing
like having uh you can teach math in a
creative way
and that's why i'm so excited that there
are these people like me you know i
write books and it's like
oh it's like i'm going to write i'm
going to write
you know um i'm going to write a girl
and a diamond
i like my opening line this is like my
new book is like she slept in an
hourglass
why not right so that's what you're
doing anyway
and it's like oh wait through glass what
is that
so i can actually give you a shape i can
introduce the shape to you creatively
and then i can actually tell you
theorems about the shape but i didn't
start with the theorems
right i started with this rough
intuitive idea
that actually had a texture to it so
people go what is it like to sleep in an
hourglass god
does do i get eaten by the sand am i the
sand does somebody turn me over what
happens when the time runs out
you know and so uh through people's
own introspection i get some really
solid thinkers
and that's what i'm after i'm not after
people wrote memorizing and like wrote
test
tests of course are difficult right but
it's
how many people remember the material
after it you know what i mean like
so memorizing through rote is not what
i'm into i'm into actually building
the inner space the inner space of
independent learners
who can think and who can
cross-reference because again i will
i'll just always say that your strongest
thinkers
are thinkers who can think along all of
those intersections right
you know if there's a problem like the
rover crashes
yeah you need your cs people but you
also need your physics people you need
your math people and that's why
you know uh normally those research
groups have that
i don't know and daniel you may have
that too right in your labs
i bet you have people from all
disciplinaries working on the inference
stuff right
species of every type of insect um well
our approach with active inference lab
is provide the affordance and the
opportunity
to co-design and wherever people are at
in learning about active inference or
curious about related topics or wanting
to apply it in some
domain we just sort of meet in the
middle
and work to use active inference as a
unifying
topic and a bridge because it um and
that's
really that's why you're here because we
actually got to intersect with
active inference coming to me all these
other ideas and what you said about the
book
reminded me of bucky fuller's tetris
scroll which is about
the goldilocks and the three bears but
the four of them are a tetrahedron
and so it talks about how the tetrahedra
is the minimal system
and there's all these tetrahedral jokes
that are embedded and so it's like
learning by doing and through stories
and through characters and by drama so
all these creative dimensions
that allow us to actually be generative
within so-called
alternate but today's alternate fashion
is tomorrow's you know out of date and
then retro
it just it's historical so how do we
respect rigor
as well as this very radically
intersubjective
like you're talking about with agents
with different perspectives but then
also we need local logics that aren't
just totally discordant because
then when we're talking about the
systems that sustain us
um we need those to also persist so how
do we
how do we that was my question is how do
we unify the rigor and the sort of
almost transcendent or at least if not
universal something like that with
intersubjective
definitions on the mortal plane right
and you can actually
see right in my talk i didn't give you
some kind of loose map very particular
right so i think i'm actually rather
gifted in that regard probably why i got
hired so quick with all this stuff is
that
i'm able to introduce an idea in a
creative way
but i give you absolute rigor so that
you know it through and through
right but i give you enough rigor to
know that object but i also endow you
with the creativity to be able to
intersect it somewhere else
else so we all say the mortal plane
right but you won't really be aware
when you pass away and you already could
have you can't prove that you exist
anyway
right so i'm like yes respect your life
force
yeah but don't ever think that you're
not infinite
because there's no proof that you aren't
right so like there's this structure
like
there is no structural causality you
know you go somewhere but you will never
be aware of it
and i all i always say uh when people
ask me that how do we how do we take
your your lovely um
you know your lovely uh um you know kind
of goodies from the higher planes
and like work with them here and i'm
like well the higher planes are here
you're in them
right it's not like it's outside of you
you know like you're born from the very
universe
it's all in you and it's sort of like i
remember when i was trying to say like
would you actually be aware when you
pass so what you won't
right and that's that's strange that's
very strange
so it seems to be this like impasse
limiting thing
all the more to value your imaginary
space
like i know when i'm trying to go to
sleep and i'm like uh
i'm like i'm gonna i'm gonna actually be
aware when i actually go to sleep you're
not
right when you go to sleep you just you
wake up right you're never actually like
aware of the moment you go to sleep
right and i'm like oh that's very
strange what is this awareness phenomena
right so yeah there is the uh i and so
when people call it mortal plane i guess
i call it the interface
that's one possible interface but again
babies can breach through it and i also
think there's other ways of getting
other interfaces yeah so how you balance
the rigor is that well
i'm giving you some of the top
mathematics like on the planet yeah
so that rigor you have to be yeah for
your own integrity
and as a pedagogue and an intellectual
of course you are
you're here to make the planet better
for everyone so you already
you have an in integrity to uh do honor
to your subject
so to do honor to your subject you learn
it perfectly yeah
but you can also know that there's
stories around it you learn the rigor
but you can also how you learn the rigor
could be creatively and it doesn't have
to be through a very
rote memorization right a category as an
object with if you learn it in a very
beautiful way
then i'm also going to honor that so
that's what i mean by like a creative
setting
i don't ever go oh yeah here's this like
diamond thing and that's it
no it's actually very specific but it's
according to who i'm talking to
if it's like super you know um uh you
know mathematicians are already this
level then i just start with that
right if i'm introducing it to
undergrads right i will start with an
intuitive
um an intuitive uh kind of um i don't
know derivative of the thing and then
actually introduce them into that
because i want them to retain it i don't
want them to shut down i don't want to
invoke their cortisol system right so
i'm really
i'm an advocate for like metacognitive
techniques so
once i um i i'm getting a really good
feel about how people learn and so the
minute you know how you think somebody
like me super abstract
throw me the intersection of something
and i'll get it right the way that you
balance
rigor and creativity is to know who the
actual learner is
yeah so who they are and it's almost
like i guess i would say my pedagogy is
like a harp and i'm tuning a harp
because i myself am a harp so the way
that you're going to actually balance
the rigor
and the creativity is for your own self
to be harp like so that i can tune to
the actual student
oh they're more of a creative i'll try
it like this oh they're more of an
engineer well
i'll i'll try an engineering i'll try a
system way right i
i just uh you know explain diamonds to
like a bunch of computer science people
and i turned it into data structures so
if i can align it with something that
they already know
for me i think that learning is about
having constellations in your head
how many constellations do you have um
can you actually link everything
together
and so if i'm if there's too much like
quote rigor
without uh you know without a creative
setting
i think i i have i will fail the people
that don't have the constellations yet
bunch of experts i could do that as well
but um you know i also nobody knows
nobody knows the consciousness realm
nobody knows what this actually is
and at least i'm open to saying that
every theorem i come up with
it's just a theorem some people think
they're absolutely right and i really
don't agree with that like at all
we have rough ideas of what it means to
do this and this but that's why i'm
asking like
what actually are the fundamental units
of life you know you can tell me when
the interface breaks
but you can't tell me about awareness
and like if i asked a neuroscience like
why can i not split the consciousness
right they would say well you know i
don't know
you know because i'm not talking about
like i'm not talking about partitioning
the brain
and you just have like two it's like
like you would see like a split screen
like those old movies i'm not talking
about that right i'm actually talking
about
double experience double experience
triple experience but not just sensory
you know
so i think i think the way that you
balance the rigor with the creativity
is to also have integrity with yourself
integrity to the subject
um anyone who actually wants to learn it
i wants to learn the specificities right
but what's what if you don't have
creativity
you'll never be able to go anywhere with
the rigor i give you if you're just
rigorous you're just going to be there
but if i can instill in you creativity
and you're actually going to be able to
take the rigor and link it
and intersect it and again if so it's
all about like
why you think you know your
phenomenological like state
i think we're here to create new things
i think being is creation
so if i can give you rigor but it can
also
hold your imaginary space then you'll be
able to take that idea like nobody else
but me would take diamonds and apply
them to consciousness
you know what i mean right so we're
getting close to
close to the end of the hour but maybe
um i'm kind of curious about about what
um
what started you in math like like how
old you were
oh totally young well i was like hmm
you know i i uh i was like what is this
thing you know what i mean
i would stare at mirrors and i'm like
that's really interesting and then
um i was basically asking my parents
like why am i not falling through the
floor
you know because i i got pretty early on
that all this stuff
sort of looked like it was made out of
the same thing and i'm like why are you
like why am i not falling through the
floor like what is holding all this
together
he's also very very curious as to why i
woke up in the same thing i was like why
am i not a lobster tomorrow so there was
some kind of stability here that i was
very perplexed by
i'm also an avid reader and when you
read there's like a voice in your head
reading and i was like who's that
who is that when people are talking to
themselves who is that
you know i was also highly aware that
when you're sleeping
who was asleep nobody was asleep if i
was up remembering dreams and things
like this
so it was very vivid you know i would
have
lots of connections with like animals
and um
you know not like body swap but it was
super super empathic
um and i would visit you know uh kind of
divine places and be like oh this is
exciting
and so what i found is that um you know
avid readers
already had the literary space but i was
like what are these
i always thought that there was
something else and so what i love about
math
right is that it was it was
um this beautiful language and a gift
that allowed me to actually
think about uh higher worlds you know in
a you know in a structured way
and so i was like oh wow this is an
actual language
and i thought that there was something
universal about it right but there's not
a lot of dialects
for math you know and it made it really
simple like oh you know category theory
hey i do
too versus like i was teaching myself
mandarin and mine i
you know i still have this california
kind of accent thing right it didn't
work so well
and so the dialects can actually hurt
language but
uh math seemed to be this like universal
way and i was like oh hey maybe we can
all
you know figure out what this thing is
again math is not it's like
my version of math you can see is very
philosophical right so it's like
um also my favorite writer was like you
know alice in wonderland and i'm like
oh through the looking glass like that's
cool and at the end he's doing all the
syllogisms
and i thought hey if you take like you
know awesome like oh
syllogisms i can just mess around with
that and i've just messed with causality
you know paradox and things like that so
super avid reader getting my hands on
big philosophy
very young and also staying open
to like to what is because i could tell
that time wasn't linear and i was like i
need a subject
but i can actually figure all this out
like time it's not linear like how can i
do that and then i
oh topology and spectral spaces and
stuff like oh it looks like that
yeah i would say it made my synthesis
like comfortable
you know what i mean yeah yeah
cool well i'm uh i don't think i have
anything else and we're getting kurds in
so
what do you think i uh would be remiss
not to ask how you thought active
inference plays into this
or what you thought about active
inference yeah without the end
like that's what you're saying right how
the interfaces actually intersect
or just right what what comes to mind
when you think about active inference
and cybernetics and control theory
and where some of this like agent in the
niche goes from
there's the analytical there's the
philosophical and then
not getting into the the theology of
what's real but just like
there's the agents the model about how
the agent is operating in the niche
so where does what does active inference
make yeah well i guess
um from like uh you know the way that
you've defined it so again i'm
interested
into okay so here's like uh i guess my
my knowledge of it right
so here's an agent with uh i mean i
guess
right with a certain interface i quote
interact with you like whatever that
means
and so in my opinion the way that things
are interacting
is through how many morphisms they
actually generate so it's actually
categorical
so i don't do this sort of like
analytical thing like philosoph
philosophical because again i i'm from
this higher space so if you just
if you look at active inference maybe
through category theory
now what's really happening it's like oh
oh interesting at what
at what instant does my interaction with
this like opposite agent or whatever
throw me into a reflective subcategory
where i'm actually just
interacting with myself so i'm really
interested
in where uh the interface theory can
actually
uh meet topological localization like i
was talking about
so i think uh what see what i like about
this is that it sounds like you're doing
the same thing that i'm doing with which
different language so a topological
localization right i'm interested in how
do you find the inverses and relate more
and make my space
stronger um you know by passing through
these reflective subcategories
and so if it's like oh if the active
inference is how these agents are
swapping and actually
interacting because that's very curious
it's very curious how what i'm taking
your information
into like my data structure and i don't
know
like what receiving looks like on that
end so i would just say that
categorically it sounds like we're doing
the same thing
and then it gets pretty meta for me when
i'm sort of like
uh i take your info and then it becomes
part of my system and it's part of my
own reflective subcategory and i like i
don't know
like keep moving on or something but you
know if it's about if
it's about how interfaces work um i
still don't know how you got the
original interface
so um i don't know if that means
anything
you know some of these ideas we talked a
little bit about
in active inference 17 2.0.1.2
because that was the paper that we
focused on for those weeks by
fields and glazebrook but i think what
you have pointed to today really
also gives us a lot of things to go over
again and think about
so maybe we can um stay in touch and
if you ever want to join for another
conversation or
participate in any other way it'd be
awesome because it's really thought
provoking and i hope
our lab enjoys it yeah so fun thank you
so much i had a great time
thank you bye